so we've been spending some time now
thinking about the idea of a fourier
series taking a periodic function and
representing it as the sum of weighted
cosines and sines and some of you might
say well how is this constant awaited
cosine or sine well you could view a sub
0 as a sub 0 times cosine of
0 t
and of course cosine of 0 t is just 1.
so just it'll just end up being a sub 0.
but that could be a weighted
cosine if you want to view it that way
and in the last video we started
leveraging some of the integrals
definite integrals of sines and cosines
to establish a formula for a sub zero
which intuitively ended up being the
average value of our function over
over one of its period or over zero to 2
pi which is the interval that we are
caring about what i want to do now is
find a general expression for a sub n
where n is not equal to 0. so for n is
greater than 0. for n is an integer
greater than 0. and i'm going to use a
very similar a very similar technique to
figure out a sub 0 i just multi i just
took the integral of both sides what i'm
going to do now is i'm going to multiply
both sides of this equation by cosine of
n t so let me do that so on the left
hand side i'm going to multiply by
cosine
of n t and on the right hand side
multiplying it by cosine and t if i
distribute that cosine of n t i'm going
to multiply every term by cosine nt so
it's going to be cosine
of n
t
cosine of nt you might see where this is
going especially because we took all
that trouble to
take to figure out the properties of
of definite integrals cosine of nt
cosine
of nt
cosine of nt or the properties of
definite integrals of products of
cosines and sines cosine of nt and this
is going to be true for all of the terms
there's an infinite number of terms here
that's what that dot dot dot is
representing we're just going to keep on
going on and on and on
and now let's take the definite integral
of both sides from 0 to 2 pi
so the definite integral from 0 to 2 pi
d t well that's going to be the integral
of this from 0 to 2 pi and actually let
me just take that coefficient out of the
integral so 0 to 2 pi
dt
0 to 2 pi
dt a little bit monotonous but it's
worth it zero to two pi
dt
zero to two pi
dt we might as well have fun while we do
it
zero
to two pi
dt
all right
zero my hand is sorting zero to two pi
d t
zero to two pi
d t once again just integration property
i'm taking the integral from zero the
definite go from zero to two pi of both
sides and i'm just saying hey the
integral of this infinite sum is equal
to the infinite sum of the different
integrals now what is this going to be
equal to
well we know we know from before that if
i just take the definite from 0 to 2 pi
of cosine nt where n is some non-zero
integer this is just going to be zero so
this whole thing is going to be zero
we also know and we've established it
before
if we take
so i just used this property we also
know if we take cosine nt times sine of
mt for any integers mt over the interval
from 0 to 2pi that's going to be 0.
and we also know
we also know that if we take the
integral of cosine mt cosine n t
where m does not equal
n where m does not equal n that that is
going to be zero
and so
we know
well here we have we're assuming that
we're assuming here that n is not equal
to one the coefficient here so that is
going to be equal to zero
this is sines and cosines with different
coefficients and frankly even if they
had the same coefficient that's going to
be zero we established that in the last
few videos this is going to be zero same
argument this is going to be zero this
is going to be zero everything's going
to be zero except for this thing right
over here but what is this thing this is
the definite what we're taking the
integral of this is the same thing as
cosine squared of n t dt the the
definitely go from 0 to 2 pi of cosine
squared nt dt
well what is that
well we established that for any m not
non-zero m this is going to be equal to
pi
so all our work is paying off
so this whole integral
this whole integral right over here is
going to evaluate to pi we did that in
another video and so now we can start
solving for a sub n we know that a sub n
times pi
a sub n times pi
is equal to
is equal to this because everything else
ended up being 0 which is very nice
it's equal to the definite integral from
0 to 2 pi of f of t
of f of t
times cosine nt
cosine
of n t
dt
cosine nt
dt and so we can now solve for a sub n
we just divide both sides by we just
divide both sides by pi and we get a sub
n is equal to i think we deserve a
little bit of a drum roll a sub n is
equal to 1 over pi
times all of this business
times the definite integral
from 0 to 2 pi
f of t
cosine nt
cosine n
t
dt
d
t so if you want to find the nth
coefficient for one of our cosines a sub
n well you take your function multiply
it times cosine of nt and then take that
definite integral from 0 to 2 pi and
then divide by pi so pretty intuitive
and what's cool is that the math kind of
works out this way that you can actually
do this so hopefully
you enjoyed that as much as i did